[Music]
hello everyone my name is john myers and
i'm here to talk to you today about the
spatial reach of brainwave
synchronization
i would like to thank lab roots for
having me today
and i would like to thank you all for
your attention
the first thing we want to talk about is
to understand the underlying nature of
brain waves we've all heard of these
things these
special
spectral changes that happen inside the
brain but what are they
so brainwaves are electromagnetic waves
that represent the flow of electrical
currents through the brain right
these currents are very complex
so they can send detailed information
across neural tissue
but why are brain waves so complex
well
there are billions of neurons
and each one has multiple electrical
fields at the sites of the synapses and
you probably already know that neurons
are connected to each other
via synapses
um
and at each one of these locations an
electrical field is generated
when you add billions of neurons
together they get mixed together and the
signal becomes very hard to interpret
for us on the back end
to record these brain waves we use many
different acquisition tools some being
non-invasive and some being invasive
the non-invasive measures include
magneto and electroencephalography
which are very similar
measurement techniques the magnetic
signal being read by
magnetoencephalography or mg
and the electrical signal is read by eeg
you can see there in the bottom that
these signals are very similar so you
kind of have a a great similarity
between electrical and magnetic
um
fields right they're just pretty much
the same signal um and so
the
in the on the right you see the invasive
measures
and we see here that there are
there on the left and brain waves there
on the right when an action potential
occurs
they contribute to the brain waves that
we read
with these electrodes here and our
non-invasive measures our invasive
measures include electro
corticography
and microelectrode arrays microelectrode
arrays
read
um
single unit activity
at a high density so they contain
hundreds of tiny needles or electrodes
that read uh neurons single cells and
these electrocorticography grids the e
cog those read
grid like brainwave activity from the
surface
of the brain itself
now these measures uh these not invasive
measures obviously require
neurosurgery right
and so how do we interpret brain waves
well if we take an example here and we
inserted an electrode
into the monkey's auditory
cortex we can use analysis tools like
this
to understand the waves themselves so if
you zoom in on that little patch of
cortex you can see
that there each little dot is a
recording
contact and if you play a sound the next
panel over in a there shows the actual
brainwaves itself if you play a sound at
this time zero you can see the brainwave
response to the sound in auditory cortex
panel b
shows us if we just
make all the negative voltages one color
and the positive voltage is another
color we can see that there is a spatial
distribution of these waveforms across
the uh across the cerebral space the
final measure here is csd or current
source density this tells us
how local the activity is this gives us
an indicator as to the current sources
and sinks or input and output of
electrical activity at that uh at this
particular location and you can see here
that across the layers of the cortex
that's one two three four five and six
you can see that there are inputs and
outputs the sources and sinks the
positive negatives the blues and the
reds you can see different distributions
of patterns there for uh for those so
this helps us interpret a particular uh
these patterns of of communication
between brain regions
so these brain regions are synchronized
right these brain waves are synchronized
within this region
um and that that gives us an indicator
as to the spatial distribution of those
of that synchronization like where the
input is where the output is
um etc right
and so
brainwave synchronization is also called
coherence
one
re the reason why we call it coherence
is because
the theory is that
when a patch a given population of
neurons synchronize with another given
patch of neurons or group
let's say cell group a and cell group e
or b there whenever they synchronize
they share information so their membrane
potentials can oscillate in a kind of
song or uh
or a symphony and when they're
synchronized at the same frequency
it is theorized that they can convey
information more easily across one
another
b and c for example have a bad phase
relationship
where
the peak of one wave corresponds to
another wave
and so
in theory these waves don't communicate
with each other as well
right so those brain regions if they are
coming from two different brain regions
or two different populations of cells
they'll communicate
less strongly than a and b will
and these
indicate structured patterns of
excitation and inhibition that's the key
idea here
is that
we know that neurons fire action
potentials right but what controls what
drives these phenomena
are neural oscillations to a large
degree
you need to have this temporally refined
control of excitation and inhibition
these on and off states have to be
controlled very systematically and
oscillations or brain waves are the way
that this is done and so we'll call this
phenomenon coherence to make things
simpler right
the phase here is the key
our second goal here now that we
understand a little bit about what
brainwaves are and how they're generated
is to understand how brainwave
synchronization might play a role in
cognition and behavior
so the first instance that i feel is
relevant
the most classical example of coherence
in many ways is
to depict cortical spinal activity like
they're just a simple movement of your
hand
and so
if you and we all know about the um you
know the cortical spinal tract the
connections between
the brain and the spinal cord and your
muscles right
so we know that here for example
if you put so they used emg in this
study
and they read the magnetic signals from
the surface of the scalp
and
they
attached a
myoelectrographic right electrode on the
muscle
in the hand
and at the time of a movement
at coherence between the electrical
activity observed at that contact on the
hand
and the magnetic which is also half
electrical activity observed on the
scalp
those activities those two different
patterns of activity are synchronized
in this frequency band this 40 to 60
hertz there
uh during movement and so it's this is a
classic example that just shows the
how coherence or brainwave
synchronization is relevant to behavior
because the simplest behavior of moving
your hand involves an increase in
coherence between motor cortex
and the neurons that cause your muscles
to move
so this suggests that there's some sort
of strong
link uh in terms of synchronization
between brain areas
and so the information is likely
conveyed via that mechanism
coherence also predicts reaction time
during focused attention this is a study
we did using eeg
electroencephalography so we just put
electrodes on the surface of the scalp
and read the currents and we use source
localization to find that these two
brain regions their coherence their
synchrony
predicts reaction time and a cognitive
control task cognitive control is just
focused attention so if i ask you to
attend to a specific object that has
many changes
um
that and you have to attend to these
different changes and respond
effectively and quickly whenever we give
people tasks like that
it's challenging and so these parts of
the brain that are involved in attention
are
activated and so their co-activation or
their shared phase or coherence predicts
reaction time
in uh in this study that we published
recently
and
the third component here
is that
coherence can
integrate sensory information
so
by sensory information i mean sight
sounds
uh
colors you know things that things that
invoke our sense perception touch
and so for this
they commonly very similarly to the
previous study they inserted an
electrode in the auditory cortex
of a monkey
and they stimulated the median nerve
and which is a nerve in your hand right
and the monkey pain as well
and so stimulation of that nerve
caused
a greater response in auditory cortex so
if you simultaneously stimulate that
nerve and play a sound you get a bigger
response in this bimodal condition
meaning two modalities of perception
you you increase the response in that
area with bimodal stimulation
whereas with somatosensory stimulation
alone which is that final box the third
one to the right there you see there's
no response in the area to just the
stimulation of the medial nerve
so synchronization between
multi-sensory areas
and
primary sensing areas like the auditory
cortex
are presumably the mechanisms that
support this kind of increased response
to uh to dual sensation events because
if you imagine the world that we live in
a lot of times the
sights and sounds are happening at the
same time so you get you get
multi-sensory integration just
effortlessly um traffic
traffic lights are often when the light
changes they are often accompanied by
changes and sounds in the environment
the sounds of engines revving up or the
sounds of breaks or things like that so
we saw our brains are very specially
designed
kind of information
very quickly
and presumably coherence is a key
mechanism for for this kind of
phenomenon
the fourth example that i want to show
you
is that coherence can link
the brain regions that underlie our
emotional experience
in life and so we've all probably heard
of the limbic system which has a part of
it as the amygdala and hippocampus
and these two regions are important for
emotions and fear
and
memory respectively remembering what
happened to us
in the past whether it was good or bad
now synchronization between these areas
can predict memory scores i mean mood
scores
memory as well in other studies but here
we're talking about mood and so lower
coherence between the hippocampus and
the amygdala predicted mood in this
study
and so
which suggests that an increased
synchronization between the highly
uh well-known emotional center of the
amygdala and the highly well-known
memory center of the hippocampus
greater synchronization between those
areas predicts
worse mood now what does that suggest
that suggests to me at least
that that increased synchronization
suggests
more
information content being shared between
this memory and an emotional region
which probably does predict and we can
see here in this line graph that it does
predict their mood
across many patients
so now that we understand a little bit
about how coherence
affects cognition and behavior and
emotions as well which is the subset of
cognition there
we can now identify some factors that
can play a role in how synchronization
spreads across the brain
and so we know now from the first
example that
signals can be somewhat coherent across
cortical layers
and we can see that here
you can see the shared phase in uh in
those raw voltage traces in the second
part of the panel there
and if we
look inside the thalamus which is a
sensory relay region in the center of
the brain
it's connected to
many different areas
subcortical and cortical areas that uh
that
carries information about our outside
world to our awareness that's uh that's
one of the main functions of this region
like quickly integrating information
about everything we're experiencing and
even things that we have experienced in
the past
and so
these different regions of this thalamus
or this relay station in the center of
the brain project different parts of the
cortex different layers
and we can see here that you have a
population of
cells called matrix neurons
and you have core neurons
these are characterized by
different protein expression levels
which are what we are depicting here
with the colors
and so
this shows that different regions of the
thalamus
project to different parts of the cortex
and that different cells are responsible
for these projections
and so that the communication between
these cells are what creates the
synchrony across brain regions and acros
and within brain regions right because
here's this is just within auditory
cortex we can see
the the phase alignment there and the
phase shift across cortical layers
this is from the same paper this shows
the distribution the spatial
distribution across the whole cortex of
these core and matrix neurons so this is
uh mrna expression levels for those of
you who want to know the exact measure
that's being looked at here so this
shows us the uh this gives us an
indicator as to the spatial
reach of these neurons that are
projected to the different layers of the
cortex as seen in the previous slide
and so you can see that there's broad
and widespread delamocortical
connectivity just connectivity between
the thalamus and the cortex the sensory
relay station and the parts of the brain
that do
the the heavy lifting the heavy
processing which is the neocortex
now coherence
in
between superficial and deep cortical
lfp
can uh
is seemingly substantiated by deep
layered action potentials right and so
we did a study where we
computed coherence or phase synchrony
between
lower level deep level
action potentials and superficial level
brain waves to see how far this spread
and so you can see here depicted this
phenomenon we call spike field coherence
spikes as an action potential single
units firing off
how are they synchronized to the
oscillations on the sensor or the
surface of the brain
and so we can see that about one to two
centimeters spread of this activity so
it suggests that single units
a bunch of single cells may be about 100
or so single neurons can measurably send
signals centimeters away
or
be synchronized with because it's
bi-directional communication
uh between
with tissue that's several centimeters
and
radius around the cell
the key idea here is that if we
if we pull all those neurons together
and just take the oscillations occurring
around them then we see an even farther
spread of this signal
so if we go back to two
there
and then we go back to this one you can
see that the spread is farther for the
pooled oscillations in the deeper
cortical areas so it suggests that these
deep cortical oscillations which are
supported by different thalamic
projections
we see that those
reach farther than the units themselves
right
so that's the key there is that
these uh that surface depth coherence
coherence between the surface of the
cortex and deeper layers can
potentially convey information farther
than
information spread within layers so i
think that's a that's a critical
observation and one that needs to be
thought about more and uh studied more
deeply in the field
but then that helps us understand how
the brain talks to itself right
how how do we compute information inside
of this
amazing
uh
computer inside of our heads
um
and so
[Music]
the next goal here
is to
and this right here shows how far it
spreads right so you have about a 20
to 30 millimeter
spread of uh coherence from a given
region
which is a pretty good distance and
farther than what we thought it was like
the spell the spread of the field
potentials that i've been showing you uh
are very uh they don't spread as far
as
shared information as a whole the phase
finally coherence connects brain regions
this is a study where they were where
participants were given a free recall
task like if i give you six words to
remember and i ask you
in five minutes to tell me which ones
you remember they were given a task like
this right
and so we can see here what this shows
is that low frequency synchronization
across all of these different brain
regions the point of this is not to
overwhelm you but to show you how
important coherence is and so
synchronization across all the different
brain regions depicted by the connecting
red dots
was
predictive of their performance in this
memory task
whereas
desynchronization which is depicted by
the blue here
and high frequencies
right so lower coherence and higher
frequencies meaning less shared
information and higher frequencies
also predicted it so this change in
greater
low frequency synchronization
lower high frequency synchronization
increased
memory performance
so what that suggests to us
is that these higher frequency
oscillations are
considered most of the time to be very
local like very constrained to a small
amount of space
whereas these lower frequency
oscillations
are
thought to be more constrained or less
constrained to local space and more
constrained to
external space
right which would explain why you would
need increased communication between
brain regions to increase your memory
performance but decreased shared
gamma information
because the gamma oscillations
presumably desynchronized might mean
that those neurons in each area are
doing their specific jobs but that the
increased synchronization at lower
frequencies
shows us
the
communication between those brain areas
so not so they're simultaneously doing
their own jobs
and sending information back and forth
at the lower frequencies i think that's
a critical idea to
to convey here
that
these different frequency bands are
conveying different information at the
same time
so imagine tuning in just like your car
when you're driving and you tune into a
radio station you're receiving inputs
from all radio stations but you tune in
to the channel that you want to get
information from
and the brain does a sim very similar
mechanism of communication
and so the take-home concepts here
are one that coherence reveals shared
information among neural populations
two
coherence is important for movement
perception emotion and thought
three
coherence is a key mechanism for
communication between brain regions
those are very important ideas coherence
is the same thing as brainwave
synchronization so keep that in mind
right you can call it coherence because
it's way less of a mouthful
i would like to thank you all for your
attention and i would like to also thank
labberds for having me on board
and here are the references for those
who want to zoom in and
make sure i said everything right
have a good one everyone
you